le district de saint-michel détient un
record peu enviable à montréal celui de
la plus forte abstention aux élections
municipales moins d'un électeur sur
quatre est allé voter ça me dit qu'il ya
du travail à faire
il a pourtant organisé des rencontres
entre candidats et citoyens des débats
mais il a une piste d'explication la
piste de la disponibilité des citoyens
et citoyennes les citoyens sont à
l'achat quand même
quotidiennement ne serait ce que pour se
nourrir pour sauver la disponibilité
c'est un luxe qu'ils peuvent pas ce pays
ici le revenu médian est 20% plus faible
que la moyenne montréalaise
la mairesse et lui promet d'aller vers
ces citoyens des intéressés faire des
consultations sur le park au coeur du
parc là où sont les gens pour les
inviter à participer à comprendre le
rôle de la municipalité dans leur vie et
je pense que ça ça va avoir un impact
bien évidemment sur le taux de
participation
au terme de ce scrutin qui a coûté 20
millions de dollars seulement 38 % de
participation élection montréal en tire
une conclusion ce que ça veut dire dans
le fond c'est qu'il ya une minorité a
décidé pour la majorité ce qui est pas
tout à fait le sens de la démocratie
mais lors des porte à porte des
candidats ont constaté que les
communications n'étaient pas claires il
ya eu beaucoup de difficulté à
comprendre qui est inscrit sur les
listes je fais partie de ces gens qui
ont reçu la lettre et qui sont dites
comment ça se fait que suis pas inscrite
sur la liste électorale les organismes
locaux ont eu beau déployer des efforts
vulgariser les informations mais malgré
tout nous sentons que qui a un blocage à
ce niveau là à tirer les conclusions qui
doivent être tirées mais il n'en demeure
pas moins qu'il ya eu quand même
beaucoup plus d'efforts cette année
qu'en 2010 est un joli 4 jours c'est 42
heures de votation contrairement à 18 et
la majorité des électeurs ont voté par
anticipation le dispositif pourrait être
répétée dans quatre ans élections au
real se dit aussi prêt à instaurer le
vote électronique qui est à l'étude à
québec ici mathieu prost radio canada
montréal